the Maclaurin series for a function f is
given by and they give it an Sigma
notation and then they expand it out for
us and converges to f of X for the
absolute value of x being less than R
where R is the radius of convergence of
the Maclaurin series Part A use the
ratio test to find R so first of all if
terms like Maclaurin series and radius
of convergence or even convergence or
ratio test seem foreign to you or you
have some foggy memories of it you might
want to review all of those concepts on
Khan Academy we actually have multiple
videos and exercises on each of these
concepts on Khan Academy but if you kind
of know what it is I will give you a
little bit of a reminder for the ratio
test so the ratio test tells us if we
have if we have an infinite series so we
go from N equals 1 to infinity and each
term is a sub n the ratio test ratio
test says all right
let's consider the ratio between
successive terms so we could say the
ratio of a sub n plus 1 over a sub N and
in particular we want to focus on the
absolute value of this ratio and this by
itself it might not be a constant like
we would see in a geometric series it
actually might be a function of N itself
and so we want to see the behavior of
this ratio as n gets really really
really large as we're kind of you know
adding those terms as we're getting
close to infinity so we'd want to take
the limit as n approaches infinity here
and if this limit exists let's say it's
L and if L if L is less than 1 then the
series the series converges converges so
what we're gonna want to do and if L is
greater than 1 it diverges it's equal to
1 it's it's inconclusive and so what we
want to do here is we want to figure out
the absolute value of the ratio here
take the limit and then see for what X
values does that limit will that limit
be less than 1 so let's do that so let's
first think about this ratio so a sub n
plus 1 over a sub n
is going to be equal to so if we put n
plus 1 into this expression here we're
gonna have so let me make this clear so
I'm gonna do a sub n plus 1 up here so
we're gonna have negative 3 and I could
write to the n plus 1 instead of an N
and then minus 1 so it would be n plus 1
minus 1 well plus 1 minus 1 is just 0 so
that's just the same thing as negative 3
to the N times X to the n plus 1 X to
the n plus 1 over n plus 1 and plus 1 so
that's a sub n plus 1 there and a sub n
well that's just negative 3 to the n
minus 1 times X to the N over N so what
does this right over here simplify to
this is going to be equal to well we
could just say this divided by thats the
same thing as multiplying by the
reciprocal of all of this stuff down
here so it's negative negative 3 to the
N X to the n plus 1 over n plus 1 times
the reciprocal of this business so times
n over over negative 3 to the n minus 1
X to the N and so can we simplify this
well we can divide both the numerator
and the denominator here by X to the N
so this divided by X to the N is just 1
this divided by X to the N is going to
be X or X to the first power and we can
divide the numerator in the denominator
by negative 3 to the N minus 1 well this
is just going to be 1 and if you divide
negative 3 to the N by negative 3 to the
N minus 1 well that's just going to be
negative 3 to the first power so this is
all going to be negative 3 X n over over
n over n plus 1 so now let's think about
what the limit of the of the absolute
value of this as n approaches infinity
is so the limit the limit as n
approaches infinity of the absolute
value of negative 3 X n over n plus 1
now some of you might recognize if we
focus on end we have the same degree up
here same degree down here this both end
to the first so these are going to the N
over n plus one is going to approach one
and so you might say okay what is going
to be the absolute value of negative
three X but if you want to make that a
little bit clearer this is equal to the
limit as n approaches infinity of and
I'll write it this way let me let me
write it so I could write the absolute
value of negative three X or the
absolute value of negative three X is
the same thing as three times the
absolute value of x times at the
absolute value of if I divide the
numerator here by n I would get one and
if I divide the denominator by n I can
do as long if I multiply or divide the
denominator by this the numerator and
the denominator by the same thing I'm
not changing it value so if I do if I
divide both of them by n and the
numerator I just get one in the
denominator and divided by n is 1 1
divided by n is plus one over n and so
this might be a little bit clearer that
ok as n approaches infinity well we
don't know this doesn't deal with n but
this over here 1 over N is going to
approach 0 and so this whole thing is
going to approach 1 and so the limit is
going to be 3 times the absolute value
of x and so remember this series
converges is if this limit if this limit
is less than 1 so converges converges
converges if 3 times the absolute value
of x is less than 1 or we could say the
absolute value of x just divide both
sides by 3 is less than 1/3 and so we
have just found our radius of
convergence R so we could say R is equal
to 1/3 this Maclaurin series is going to
converge as long as the absolute value
of x is less than 1/3 or we could say
our radius of convergence is equal to
the our radius of convergence is equal
to 1/3 so there you go